Gary what's the greatest script you've
ever read and what happened to that
script
you know I've read a lot of what I would
consider I've been blessed to read a lot
of great scripts and some of them never
got made fortunately many have I
remember reading the million dollar
hotel by a friend of mine
Nicholas Klein and I was so bottom
endlessly in love with that script and I
wanted him to direct he'd never directed
it ended up being directed by Ben
venders and in my estimation I it was
not it was it it didn't have the poetry
that was Nicholas that was infused in in
it because of who he was no disrespect
of an vendor season you know lauded film
maker of course and but but so you know
in that case it kind of went one
direction pretty woman before it was
pretty woman 3000 by jf Lawton was
certainly I certainly at that time it
was the best script I'd ever hauled in
my hands and it was a dark drama of
course but it was absolutely riveting
compelling beautiful in a in a sort of
you know tragic sense and of course as
we know that film did get made only it
got and and and ironically the film got
made so true to its original form but
just the structure and the characters in
that I was so taught that we didn't have
to labor too hard to turn it tonally and
of course we had Gary Marshall so he
could improv anything yeah he filmed it
as it was and then he did a little
improv and we found that sort of comedy
in it so that God made again in a
totally unexpected direction originally
it was going to be a dark independent
you know few million dollar film so you
never know these things always take left
turns news
and but there have been a lot of great
scripts but you know sadly that didn't
get made I remember there was a little
film called The Cure that I was madly in
love with the very special care little
small script young characters and I had
actually shared that with Steven
Spielberg and his people flipped out and
then Steven fell in love with it and we
were cranking up the the offer from
Universal and Universal and Warner
Brothers simultaneously and and the the
agent actually sold the script overnight
to a third party and it got made years
later as a low-budget kind of non-event
that was the biggest heartbreak
personally for me but you know you never
know there are scripts that and there
probably some scripts today that will
still haven't been made that will get
made but I thought that I think are
amazing it just you there's no there's
no predicting this business so what was
it about that script that you said was
eventually sold to a third party I mean
what was it that just really resonated
with you it was just a personal thing
that you thought that you felt a
connection to or the way it was written
the voice of the protagonist it it what
was so remarkable about it was there are
there are characters and stories that
are so gorgeous
because of their truth because they call
to us they penetrate us in a way that's
undeniable that we have all of us had
that experience growing up and this was
about growing up young characters and
any anyone who has blood flowing through
their veins would have recognized some
part of themselves or their friends in
that story in a very poignant context
and and because it was so Universal and
so sweetly done not it wasn't a sweet
picture it was it was a challenging
story but at what was sweet about it was
the the attention to detail the truth of
how it played out
you